post-show honestly I'm doing really good
I'm extremely happy it feels so good to
be able to say that I am very very happy
with oneself Peter Webber has finally
found his happily ever after with Kelly
Flanagan I'm Kelly's biggest fan and I
will say that just to recap pilot Pete
season of The Bachelor might have
actually been the most dramatic season
ever
first he proposed to Hannah Anschluss
dear beautiful spirit is honestly like
anything I've ever seen before
then he ended their engagement I said
yes and I get this
and pick things back up with his
runner-up Madison Pruitt I love Peter
and that like hasn't changed since that
day in Australia but his mom Barbara not
impressed
the next day we met Madison and it's
started on a rocky road because she had
us wait three hours for her to come in -
she didn't want to meet us she totally
didn't approve and just a few days later
Peter and Madison split whoa still with
me well just a few weeks after that the
28-year old pilot started dating another
ex contestant Kelly and from the looks
of it they're in it for the long haul
I couldn't have expected any of that to
go the way it did but I can't say that
I'm very happy with how everything ended
up the two went public with their
relationship on May 2nd when P chaired
this puckered up pic on Instagram
writing you caught me
let the adventure begin but before they
announced their love to the world they
quarantined together in her hometown
Chicago ah romance and the time of
quarantine yeah it must be love people
well then they headed back to Pete's
hometown Westlake Village California
and on Monday season premiere of The
Bachelor the greatest seasons ever they
said they couldn't be happier
hosts show honestly I'm doing really
good I'm extremely happy it feels so
good to be able to say that and yeah
it's very hopeful for the future listen
if you're thriving under quarantine she
might actually be your girl as for Kelly
she opened up about how things didn't
work out for them on the show but says
it's all water under the bridge
we are just you know really excited for
the future when this whole thing finally
ends we've talked about we both have
dreams I'd love to live in New York City
for a little bit and get that experience
so hopefully fingers crossed that's in
our future and just just enjoy each
other and it's been great
so I know what you're wondering what
does barb think of all this so much we
get along so great and it's like you
know the daughter that I've always
wanted yeah that's not so surprising to
us because back in March Kelly told et
barb was her number one fan from when I
learned those Barb's are huge family
she stands Kelly uh which I just learned
which is really funny but how did you
learn that because I saw her at the
finale what did she say to you it would
not leave the finale until she met me
what did you and Barb say we just had
small talk but over to be honest the
majority of it was her hugging me
beautiful and Peter well he says he's
finally found his happily ever after
I remember going in and I just I wanted
that love story more than anything and I
can honestly say that it works for me in
the end so thank you thank you thank
bass nation for sticking by me all my
craziness but it all worked out
[Music]